we had a potential brand integration
with tom cruise like we were gonna go to
like
he's literally here
tom cruise is here right now yeah i just
from what i hear he's one of the nicest
most professional people i mean i just
can't say enough about how much of a
special honor this is
he's he's right there he's right there
he's outside
okay
girl he's like my favorite dude i'm
trying to be natural i don't want to be
awkward just be yourselves
hey how you doing good how are you i'm
not going to be here nice to meet you
nico hey nick good to meet you clinton
yes i've heard a lot about you
how is taz tether going is is it good uh
you got the financing yet
we've been struggling with that a little
bit well you know it takes time but you
know i'm here to help i'm a helper yeah
that's what i do help me help you
yeah i mean we would love you to just
help us any way you can with that well
tell me about dobby is dobie causing you
trouble still every day how do you know
about dobie i i follow i follow
everything i mean i might
got my finger on the pulse you know i'm
in the zeitgeist
you follow us oh i follow you yeah i
know everything about you wait are you
seeing the channel right around the bell
yeah to get a little subscription plus
action yeah and i'm i'm having the time
of my life it's such an honor oh it's an
honor and a privilege don't forget that
yeah that's so cool did you see the tom
cruise impersonation like olympics that
we did yes yes and i heard you won you
you tucked your shirt
well you know what can you untuck it
while i'm here because it's making me a
little uncomfortable
uh sure yeah yeah just just right now
thank you because it's just a fun thing
i know i know but it's past it's in the
past and i live in the moment you know
that's true yeah yeah totally me too
good yeah well let's let's let's uh show
me around won't you yeah show me how
where all the magic happens
i love the water yeah maybe a pastrami
sandwich thank you so if you couldn't
already tell this is not the real tom
cruise it's actually a deep fake and
here's how we made it
i actually have some slight adrenaline
going my heart is fluttering right now
what we're trying here could get real
crazy down the line
it doesn't look that great
two words do you want to sam nico deep
fakes
president trump is a total and complete
difference
find them show me your leadership
capability
deep fake is basically training a
computer based on pattern and image
recognition to understand the structure
of a human face and one of the
byproducts of this is that you can
accurately replicate someone else's face
onto another person's face now this gave
me an idea i want to put tom cruise
tom cruise i want to put his face on a
celebrity impersonator
back to normal niko someone that can act
like tom cruise someone that looks like
tom cruise someone that sounds like tom
cruise
would it be indistinguishable from the
real thing does this mean that you can
put any movie star you want into your
videos if these deep fakes end up
working this could have some pretty big
implications in the world of not only
film and television but also news and
media and if it doesn't look good then
we got some solid nightmare fuel coming
up so let's go see what happens
yo what's up do you know
any celebrity impersonators yeah i mean
kind of funny literally just over this
weekend justin bieber tweeted that he
wants to take tom cruise in a fight in
the octagon i don't know why but this
official tom cruise impersonator replied
looks exactly like tom cruise i don't
normally fight girls justine bieber
dude he looks just like him yeah he's
that guy from l.a yes i believe he is i
think we sent that guy a dm he would
respond to us
not tom cruise be in our video i'm going
to tweet you right now
all right so i'm going to be using a
program called deep face lab it's
actually free get on github now if you
want to deep fakes of your own you're
going to need a pretty decent graphics
card and you need a lot of video ram
thanks to puget setting us up with a
solid workstation here i can run these
deep fakes on this computer in pretty
high resolution without too much strain
if you want to see what kind of specs a
fugit has there's a link in the
description below here is my source
video of my face the more structure the
more variations i can give the program
with my face the more the program can
learn what happens i think one of the
issues people have said is like hey i
deep faked this person but they don't
blink at all and that's because they
don't have any frames for it to learn
where the eyes are closed you make sure
you provide it with all these different
poses all these different profiles and
perspectives and now i'm going to be
putting it on rin here so once i'm ready
to go once i have my two video clips i
need to extract the faces the program's
going in and actually doing some facial
recognition here are the eyes here's the
nose here's the mouth just to isolate
the face and align it once i've
extracted the faces i need to train the
program into how the faces work the
faces on the left are the ground truth
so to speak they are my face from a
picture the blurry thing next to it is a
program going through iteration by
iteration by iteration looking at the
pictures and trying to learn and trying
to match it and the closer it can get
its artificially generated image to the
actual ground truth image the better
it's doing little by little videos
become clearer and clearer then we have
ren his ground truth of his face in the
synthesized version of his face and then
on the far right we see the computer
trying to recreate my face based on
wren's structure so a friend's making a
funny face with his mouth open the
computer is trying to go okay what would
nico's face look like with the mouth
open and it's trying to put my face into
that pose basically anytime bran's
expressions don't match things that i've
done the computer's having a hard time
filling in the gaps it needs a little
more training as to what that looks like
so i could go back and try to find more
pictures of me in that pose i could just
take pictures anyway should clean that
up for the sake of this test i'm not too
worried about that if i have any issues
like this in the tom cruise test i will
go through and find pieces i need to fix
it to make sure that it's flawless this
guy is really talented so these deep
fakes are pretty sweet right but i
wanted to let you guys in on a little
secret of something that i've been doing
that's even more convincing it's called
shallow fakes and shallow fakes are so
simple and easy to use that it's almost
like today's sponsor squarespace it
looks just like them it does if i put
this on i can go around and actually
convince people in the studio that i'm
nico here ready just wait
niko hey nick
you guys might have thought that that
was nico it's jake
let's go out there
hey christian what's up nico would you
mind if i told you a little something
about today's sponsor squarespace sure
squarespace is an all-in-one platform
it's the best way to build a business or
just a website online thanks niko you're
welcome
it's totally working what are you
working
on nico you look a little pale i'm still
waiting for summer to come in beautiful
thing about squarespace is that you can
do simultaneous posting where if you
post something on squarespace you can
also show up on your twitter and
facebook feed isn't that cool yeah i
didn't actually know you could do that i
think jake learned today that you can
post audio like a podcast onto
squarespace it'll just embed it and make
it easy to access for all your fans they
have multiple contributors you guys
could contribute to orderdigital.com hey
would you would you like to would you
like to go on a one-wheel ride later i'm
one meal it's kind of batteries but do
you want to make cheese or sausage later
i'm a little full but i'll be hungry
eventually cool hey dean hey how have
your first few weeks been here at
corridor they've been uh great nico
thanks thanks for asking dean
squarespace allows you to own all the
content that you post on your website
apparently there are some rumors out
there where you didn't own the content
that you posted on squarespace that's
untrue do i look like i'd lie about that
no no nico i don't think you
would so there you have it oh jen's
coming jan's gonna be here any minute
[Applause]
don't go out there nico be careful where
is that nico it is i niko
[Music]
it's just me holy [ __ ]
what's up man hey they're looking for
you
if you guys are interested in creating
your own beautiful website go to
squarespace.com corridor crew and you'll
get 10
off your first purchase of a url or a
website template enjoy
all right niko evan ferrante aka not tom
cruise is confirmed coming on wednesday
he's down oh sweet you think he can run
at as much of an angle as i can i'm just
excited to have a celebrity impersonator
in the studio this works it's going to
look pretty bizarre it's going to look
like he's here
hey everyone nice to meet you hey nico
yes evan yeah jake what's up jake nice
to meet you yeah when did you realize
this was a thing my friend he does a
jean-claude van damme impression does he
do the splits he didn't do the split so
he did that bit and he said you sound
and look and have the mannerisms of
crews and he said let's like team up and
meet women this way and i didn't even
have glasses at the time i didn't have a
wig which i'd do today i don't wanna i
don't like to break the illusion and it
turned into a career so it's totally
surreal i've had like a little bit of a
loss of identity through the years like
i'm like who am i have you ever met tom
cruise
you have i didn't go to sleep that night
i went i was at the chateau as one does
you know like i knew someone at another
table this attorney guy he called me
over and he said i heard tom cruise is
in the building i had been impersonating
him for eight years at that time but my
heart was racing you know i was getting
sweaty he wasn't there like and i go
back to my seat kind of resigned to the
fact that i wasn't gonna meet him i just
suddenly feel like this energy to the
side of me he's right there yeah but you
cannot you cannot talk to celebrities in
the garden you cannot talk to tom cruise
he kind of gets up and like you know
shakes people and just like it says
goodbye and i'm just like this is
amazing that's what i do he leaves it's
just me and my friend jimmy in the
garden that's it it's two in the morning
and suddenly he gets a call he said to
me tom cruise is waiting for you in the
lobby no and i
said i said shut the he was and i get up
out of my chair i sprint from the garden
i just sprint
he was there waiting for me it's i swear
time stopped it was like a slow turn and
we it's like a cataclysmic reaction we
just like mutual appreciation admiration
we both said at the same time it's an
honor and a privilege to meet you
i could not it was the most surreal
thing ever the most exciting moment of
my life nothing else mattered except for
us in that moment we fell in love
that's great i'd like to show you the
technology that we face please a little
intro to the video where i'm talking
about the technology yeah and i flip my
face oh my god
and that's tom on you yeah it's very
scary the computer computer's learning
the actual structure of tom cruise's
mannerisms and expressions it's learning
it yeah but we did a we did a tom cruise
contest uh okay a few months back i did
end up winning could you give us an
example of yeah what is it you do i'll
just do a little montage let's see what
it's like without any deep fake right
now let's see how close we get
this is clint this is it this is it he's
got to make sure the hair is okay but
already you start to hear it in my voice
and i'm just going to do a countdown
okay five
four
three
two
you don't know what it's like to be out
here
for you it is a pride swallowing up a
dawn siege that i can never fully tell
you about just help me help you help me
help
you wow
tom it's great to see you hey it's great
to be here
what's your name my name is nico my name
is nico yeah i forgot i have a short
term memory i shake a lot of hands you
know i'm a huge fan
i'm a fan of you thank you
i'm a fan you know you work with such
incredible you know people around you
and i really i really sense your passion
here ryan will you do me the honors
here's the finger point
oh it's a privilege man it's an honor to
prove an honor and a privilege yeah wow
dude it's breathtaking i feel it too you
know i feel you know he's very composed
but when i do it i just you know i get i
get caught up in it i try to channel him
nico do we need the deep fake i'm not
sure we need the deep fake can you do
better than this i don't know i don't
know
you're gonna break the ai yeah and i
wasn't joking before i do have somewhat
of a loss of identity through the years
from doing it so much you know i mean
there's not a day that goes by that i
don't get asked to do it i love doing it
and it gives me a lot of joy to do it so
look i feel a little bit naked without
the glasses i will hide behind the deep
fake but i will also merge with it i
will i will become one when it comes to
deep fix all it is is mass yeah you
still need the craft you still need the
inflection you still need the mannerisms
if you can act and then wear that mask
yeah that's when you reach a full
character for sure i'm really excited
about it i'm supposed to do that
so i've done 250 000 iterations it's
been baking for days and days i have
still lots of small problems to work out
but this is the version now and it's
pretty crazy
i'm supposed to do that right
now so obviously the color hasn't been
matched yet
it looks really good but we're not quite
there yet i think we all have like
little ideas on what is making it fall
short of perfection i mean the obvious
things are the eyeball his face is
almost too big on his face i think that
is true it's like his head shape isn't
perfectly matched to tom cruise i mean
you guys have already seen the scene in
the video but yeah at this point we
haven't made them yet so we have a lot
of shots of tom cruise in like some
pretty complex motions so i don't know
the big thing i gotta do is i just gotta
keep feeding it tom cruise source
material feed me i'm hungry i'm gonna
start a new model fresh here from
scratch really i'm gonna up the
resolution of everything to where i go
out of memory of my card as close as i
can get so you're gonna be quadrupling
the resolution i think the higher the
resolution will fix the wonky eye if
you're going four times higher
resolution that means it's going to take
four times
as much time yes it will are you just
gonna have a train all weekend you bet
man you bet it's a slow cooker i got a
tom cruise pot roast going
all right so these tom cruise cookies
are baking in the oven all weekend so it
should be really nice we've invited evan
back in and i get to show him basically
this full transformation here i'm really
excited you know it's just this
beautiful coming together moment i hope
he likes it there's been a lot of a lot
of build up but i feel like this is
going to exceed my expectations
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
[Laughter]
wow kind of a blank stare but i like it
it is uncanny
you kept that one wow this this is very
exciting it's it's a combination of
terrifying but also incredibly
entertaining the way the wrinkles are
forming on your cheeks yeah it's getting
the proper like folds on the cheeks and
lips and all this but those are his
teeth completely is that what that is
that's 100 and his tongue is in there
that's his tongue yep okay because once
you train the face it's not that hard to
put it on new faces like i could we
could film with you for another minute
here and i could have it
face swapping by the end of the hour
like i have been studying your face your
two faces yeah of course yes
the thing that really sets this apart
from any other defect out there honestly
is
your voice there's no deep fake for
voice right now so you're giving us a
voice that is elevating anything visual
that we're doing this is my new crutch
that i lean on you know
i do have someone of a loss of identity
through the years i'm doing it so much
you know i will hide behind the deep
fake but i will also merge
i will become one this is as far as i've
come to you know becoming conjoined yes
i've melted
[Music]
i would love to
hear tom's reaction if you just if you
just looked over and she's like dude
how amazing it would be if you just said
anything
thank you so much for lending us your
talents skills and abilities and all of
our entire honor privilege
[Music]
hey guys tom cruise here back in the
corridor digital studio i just wanted to
say they have a wonderful patreon where
they've got all these great people who
support the videos that they make like
this one right here this is wendy
deptula hi thanks wendy for supporting
us on patreon and this guy right here
phillip oxford are you are you astro
gigi either way it's an honor and a
pleasure to meet you
hey are you alan almanza
hey how are you hey good to see you are
you watching the lions head youtube
channel because they support us too i
will be i will be great and just
remember
warmaster236 and matt he are also great
patreon supporters that's so crazy here
you will robertson oh yeah you're not a
canadian spy or eddie adolf they all
support us too i think i'm all of them a
little bit i think i am too
hey guy are you a rino guerrero mitch
palinski or glitch cube i can't quite
tell hey i'm talking honor and pleasure
to meet you thanks for being here hey
guy hey tom welcome back are you james
bailey or raymond dabot i'm bryan and
tozic hey brian how are you
everyone on that list so phenomenal
can't say enough about them they got me
down here right finger on the pulse all
that stuff hit the button got the
notification squad going consider
supporting these guys patreon.com slash
quarter quarter digital
okay i'll see you guys later see you
next week
[Music]
you